[Musique]
50 000 touristes visitaient Washington DC
chaque jour mais ma partie de la ville ils
ne voient jamais ici les gangs dans la rue
ce mot pour le plus gros gang autour
du ms-13 je ne veux pas qu'ils aient ce
genre de vie  Je ne veux pas faire partie
du jeu, tu peux sortir d'ici
pourquoi y pensait-il et il est
parti vert tu sais genre de coutume de le
prendre comme un homme
quoi que tu fasses ne pleure pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissement  ]
baise les briques je veux le gamin mon
frère que faire
je l'ai élevé tout seul laissez nous tranquille je
pense que d'accord les gars vous regarderiez ça sur
le mariage de ma soeur [ __ ] de merde j'étais comme
un père pour vous je vous échange comme mon  fils
regarde moi tu sais ce qu'ils vont
te faire
hé ce que tu fais ici mec blanc
[Musique]
toi